forest tourisme villégiature plat mrc de
papineau dans l'outaouais est surnommé
le pays de l'or vert devra-t-on biais de
y ajouter leur grille à trois kilomètres
de l'immense lac simon et juste à côté
du lac doré une mine de graphite
pourrait voir le jour dans cinq ans la
compagnie canadienne le mic au métal y
détient des droits d'exploration sur une
bande de 15 km ce qu'on appelle un clé
min on a eu je vous dirais que la chance
d'avoir un actif qui avait que le forage
est démontré qu'il y avait une valeur du
canal sites de qualité supérieure encore
bien des étapes sont à franchir mais
l'entreprise est optimiste le graphite
est un minéral utilisé dans
l'électrification des transports et
québec proclame maintenant vouloir
devenir la batterie du nord-est
américain toute la chaîne des minéraux
critique et stratégiques on veut la voir
au québec pour se positionner comme un
leader on n'est plus dans la guerre du
pétrole dans guerre dans l'ère de la
guerre des minéraux stratégiques
résidents du secteur louis saint-hilaire
milite depuis deux ans contre le projet
installé ça dans des lieux comme ici
pour moi au début mais pour tout le
monde à qui on ne parle et c'est
inacceptable c'est changer c'est comme
installer un parc industriel en pleine
nature ils s'inquiètent aussi de la
multiplication des clés milliers dans
les zones de villégiature photo dc d'un
et dans les laurentides et dans
lanaudière
c'est des terres de la couronne et ce à
n'importe qui peut réclamer ça pour
faire du forage on constate une
explosion des clés min dans certains
secteurs du québec surtout dans le sud
lapointe a fondé la coalition pour que
le québec ait meilleure mine le sud de
la province dit il abonde de minéraux
stratégiques pour électrifier les
transports 2019 par exemple selon les
chiffres du ministère des mines c'est
l'année record des investissements pour
le lithium est gratuite au québec la une
thèmes d'exploration donc les gens
commencent à voir ses foreuses là des
gens commencent à voir les hélicoptères
avec les machines géophysique voler
au-dessus l'heure de leur milieu et
s'inquiètent et on va avoir de plus en
plus
sur cette carte de l'outaouais des
laurentides et de lanaudière toutes les
zones rouges représentent des clés
minier et beaucoup concernent le
graphite en outaouais leur nombre n'a
pas changé de 2015 à 2020 il y en avait
81 mais dans les laurentides
le nombre de clim de grafite est passé
de 88 à 171 en cinq ans et dans
lanaudière il est passé de 129 à 301
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette région que
se trouve le projet le plus avancé celui
de nouveaux mondes graphite à saint
michel des saints québec lui a donné son
aval la coupe forestière est commencée
et la future mine aura une longueur de
2,6 km
il n'y a pas tellement territoire dans
les laurentides qui pourraient être
susceptibles à l'implantation d'une mine
à cause de notes
notre vocation de villégiature maire
d'amiens sud ouest de mont tremblant
jean-guy galipeau rappelle que clim de
grafite existe déjà dans ces
municipalités
mais il est inactif pour l'instant six
étaient exploitées de façon
logique c'est à dire un respect de
l'environnement tout ça je pense qu'on
serait pas content soldes de créer de
l'emploi mais parce qu'on a un grand
territoire en marche de 249 km crevé
mais c'est pas le cas pour l'ensemble la
mrc des laurentides
des dizaines de municipalités qui se
mobilisent actuellement dans le sud du
québec face à cet enjeu est actuellement
les lois et les règlements du québec
sont pas bien outillés pour gérer cette
harmonisation des activités économiques
c'est inquiétant s'inquiétant pour des
communautés des gens préfet de la mrc de
papineau benoît lauzon voudrait pouvoir
interdire les clés min dès que des
résidences se trouvent aux abords d'un
lac ce qu'il ne peut pas faire
actuellement n'est pas capable de bien
protéger nos lacs et nos rivières quand
on travaille avec les critères du
gouvernement présentement on est capable
de protéger après 50 9 % de notre
territoire
puisqu'on demande au gouvernement quand
on a déposé une demande au gouvernement
il y avait 11 % de plus qu on demande
qui était celle à
90 résidences se trouve autour du lac
doré ou lomic au métal souhaite
implanter son projet la plaine et existe
la compo on peut pour arrêter un clean
cut existe ça qu'on va travailler avec
ces gens le prenaient décidé d'anticiper
sur les préoccupations de comprendre où
on est et pour s'assurer qu'on ne
dérange pas ou qu'on ait une empreinte
absolument minimale au niveau de l'eau
de tout ce qui est des milieux humides
même visuel même au niveau du bruit il
pourra scanner de l'action là que même
pas de limitation parce qu'il ya pas de
construction ce ce côté là il pourrait
être loué saint-hilaire demeurent
inquiets même si ces démarches ont
convaincu plusieurs élus régionaux de
monter aux barricades
quand on arrive à québec sable le sable
c'est qu' aucun intérêt à changer les
règles pour définir
il y en a aucun os 4 au cas où aucune
volonté politique il craint que devenir
la batterie et du nord-est américain
soit un gros prix à payer pour bien des
résidents du sud du québec ici j'en sais
pas c'est l'outil radio canada lacc
ciment